such diis who come with females and
women and interact freely these are D on
the gates of Hellfire Subhan Allah to
accuse us of chitchatting with sisters I
went to him and he allowed me to make
his fatwa public here's what he said
brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing D
that you want to do but we turn it into
a money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true brothers and sisters and dear
friends I urge you guys in to watch this
video in full there'll be so much stuff
that you guys will learn inah before I
even mention the two alims um subh Allah
that we got the fatwa for when it comes
to the bitu show which there has been a
big controversy on if you are truly
wanting to follow the Quran and the
Sunnah and it's not about your
or this that and nothing personal you
will listen to this video and say you
know what no problem he went to people
of knowledge and you will leave it at
that I'm going to be talking strictly
strictly from the Quran and Sunnah I do
not take my over the what does this mean
Shan was ordered to bow down to Adam
which is a command from Allah subhana
tal which is from the knle what Allah
commanded he rather took hisle and said
hold on a second I logically thinking
I'm better than him so he fell into this
belief by rejecting the KN and taking
his now we know some people claim or
blame a certain sex group that they do
this they take the over the sadly our
salafi brothers do the same thing they
take the over the knuckle when it comes
to issues pertaining to these matters
they think their level or what they deem
to be right or inappropriate is decides
brother I follow the Quran and the
Sunnah I follow the Quran and the Sunnah
and I have evidences from the Quran and
the Sunnah so I don't follow anyone's
opinion I'm going to mention the two
alims who have been both praised by bin
baz one of them has been sent to the UK
directly by she bin baz may Allah Mery
on him to give da in the UK number one
and he is definitely known the salafi
circles and that's the reason I went to
him just for those who reject the first
one another one is Subhan Allah which
I'm going to mention to you guys which
he needs no in in introduction Subhan
Allah he was directly praised by bin baz
to teach in Saudi Arabia there was a
discussion happened between them and
said Tim my son you can teach anywhere
in the Kingdom so this issue also
pertains to the ruling that was given by
sheim alhim now why am I bringing this
because I have all respect for him he's
Elder he is senior in knowledge and
Senior in age may Allah bless and
preserve him and I understand he's
trying his best to give the best rulings
for the umah however there are some
things that he was said that he said
which was very very problematic because
people follow him which is that and
again it's an assumption that we are
calling people to the gates of the
Hellfire that's such a such a big claim
such di who come with females and women
and interact freely and these are dies
on the gates of Hellfire like the
prophet said Alam because this is not
Islam Subhan Allah to accuse us of
chitchatting with
sisters and anyone that knows brothers
and sisters knows Subhan Allah that we
are orthos Muslims we follow the Quran
and the Sunnah and they know what we're
about alhamdulillah yes we are not
liberals free mixing is Haram nobody I
have never ever said free mixing is
halal how can I say something that is
Haram and I make it Halal who am I I'm
an absolute nobody I'm a no one so I
have never ever said free mixing is
halal free mixing is chitchatting
talking
intermingling with men and women this
opens the doors to F Haram and many
other diseases all the way after to Z
that's what Allah says in the
Quran don't even come near it so it is
better that men and women do not
unnecessarily without need intermingle
chat going to shabas going to weddings
which is mixed going to shabas it's
mixed why are you going to a wedding
that's mixed why alhamdulillah whoever
knows me personally my wedding was fully
segregated I do not intermingle with
women I only talk to them if there's a
necessity and that is the thing that we
follow which was given to us by our
teachers Speakers Corner otherwise
Speakers Corner is free mixing we were
told that it has to be in public it has
to be pertaining to daah and when the
conversation is gone you go your
separate way ways that is exactly the
principle we follow so there is free
mixing and there is mixing which is
permissible and allowed we are seeing
and our claim is not from us from the
scholars we got the fatwa from is that
bitter truth show is not free mixing and
that is the fat we gave so put me out of
the equation between myself and said
there is a mountain of difference of
knowledge and age the same thing applies
for these two
who gave us the
F Allah bless and preserve him has
admitted himself in a video clip which
I'll play that he is not a scholar he
only calls
from so he is outright telling you he's
not a scholar Essence and the default is
that Layman follow Scholars and I'm not
a scholar however whatever I convey to
you is taken
from
99.99% so in by following what I say and
you can always test me or cross
reference with the real Scholars of and
and if you find that it complies with
what they had said then you are in the
safe no problem he is telling you what
they have said so he even quoted I think
in one of his Instagram saying that he
replying to me that he follows the
opinion of Bin Bas when it comes to his
matter that's fine I respect that but
now we have two people who have been
directly praised by bin Bas who gave us
the fatwa and I'm going to play that
recording for you guys inshallah
brothers and sister so number one free
mixing is absolutely Haram mixing is not
free mixing mixing is something when
there is a need I'm not a necessity I'm
not talking life and death where there
is a need and many of you guys will
accept that and understand that that
happens into our day-to-day lives some
brothers come to me and say that would
you want your wife on the show and I'm
thinking to myself Subhan Allah the
argument is not even that because a hook
a ruling in Islam is not based on what I
say for example if I go to a man and I
say to him would you want someone
sleeping with your wife and he goes yeah
I have no problem does that become Halal
now sleeping somebody sleeping with his
wife does it become Halal now no it
doesn't a hook is not based on a
individual saying yeah I have no uh
problem my daughter having a boyfriend
we you going to what you going to say oh
my gosh so the point here is to show
that please Brothers Let's educate
oursel the question here has been asked
is number one would I want that let's go
with argument sake that I don't how does
that make the ruling impermissible Hal
is it based on what I say no it does not
so but just the answer I have no problem
at all that if my wife was a marriage
counselor or somebody who had something
to offer the show I would tell her I
would like you to wear n yes
alhamdulillah go to the show to benefit
the people because we've got a pandemic
of divorce R happening family's breaking
down suffering that is the reason we
start the of show I have no
problem and I also even asked my wife I
said it's better if you come on to the
show even if you're not speaking well
she doesn't want to speak anyway with
her whiteboard may Allah bless her to
sit next to me so I don't need to push
myself to the corner cuz the room is
already tight and we put the sers as
much uh apart as we can but she doesn't
want to and I respect her decision so I
want to make it categorically clear
because I'm not going to be someone
who's has an issue because I don't
believe there is nothing wrong with the
setting to then want it for for other
people's sisters and daughters and
mothers and that when it's my wife I go
no no no so let me make that clear I
have zero problem with my wife being on
the show and contributing she doesn't
want to number one fatwa that was given
to us by both alims and both gave the
permission and by the way I did not want
them their names to be mentioned because
of ignorant ignoramus Jah five star
grade A jahss who go and slander them
with zero
knowledge you know both of them I'm sure
very very well very well and you can
speak to them because the accusation of
calling people to the gates of the
Hellfire it's not Al Al Tak me out of it
now that's the F we gave we got why cuz
what does Allah subhana say in the Quran
cuz we did exactly what Allah says in
the Quran Allah says in the Quran inah
verse
43 ask the people of knowledge if you do
not know and that is exactly what we did
and we got the fatwa and we are basing
on that fatwa and now we are being
accused by
that we are calling people to the gates
of the Hellfire now like I said before
this is not my issue now the accusation
is on the two alims that gave us his
fatwa so I'm going to leave the matter
toim he can call them and clarify the
matter for that matter in yeah so now
when it comes to the issue of may Allah
bless and preserve him like I said
before I have love for him but to come
and say such b statements and make it
seem as if that this is the opinion is
very dangerous and and understand that
he believes that he follows a correct
opinion but that is your opinion my dear
may Allah bless and preserve you why
because the people who are following his
fatwa that was not from him by the way
because he clearly says he's a high
student of knowledge or a student of
knowledge for that matter and he gets it
from these Scholars well and good we
have gone to other Scholars Subhan Allah
because we don't
believe are the only scholars in the
world yes so one thing I want to mention
is very clearly this if you are going to
follow Al's opinion this matter now you
cannot pick and choose and say okay this
is the opinion and there's no there's no
other uh opinion because we know a very
simple uh principle subh in Islam that
it
is which is what that there is there is
no rebuking in the matters of difference
of opinion there is you cannot come and
rebuke somebody else if they hold their
hand praying here or not because if
you're going to do that the question is
very clear then you need to follow
alim's all of his opinions for example
number one he believes that the face is
a that your wife your sister your mother
and your daughter has to wear a now if
you come and say no no no I don't follow
the opinion I say well hold on a second
brother why are you picking and choosing
why is it when it com to the bit trip
show what said is the opinion no other
opinions okay but when it comes to him
telling you that the face is a and
majority of you guys is your wife's
wearing bro she isn't isn't she no she
isn't is your wife mother wear no she's
not is your daughter wearing no she's
not is your sister wearing no she's not
now am I going to come and say say hold
on a second according to I say you like
now are you a the youth are you a man
who has no protective jealousy do do you
have over your woman folk men are seeing
her face I don't care if she has no make
makeup or no makeup when she's going
outside men are going to look at her is
this the yard stick now do you follow
the opinion oh it's a difference opin oh
you don't follow it interesting good
number two do you follow for example
number one is there any the prophet PE
upon him said there is no n without a
yes but what about the hanis what about
the Han there is
b b consensus that if a Hani man and a
hany woman is married nobody can say
this is Zena nobody can say this is Zena
you can say you different opinion look
this is the matter of
now you get it but that's the opinion
and even the salafi scholars bin all of
them will say that if the hanis follow
this if it's Hy man and a woman you
cannot say they are committing Z you
cannot this is why I'm telling we are
learning today number three uh when it
comes to Subhan Allah's opinion that a
woman can write in a contract that she
cannot a husband should not get a second
wife and we know very simple from the
principles of the four Ms that anything
that is a battle in the contract yes
from its get-go is rejected you get it
the assle of the contract is batted you
are saying you're trying to make
something Hal something so the contract
is invalid
but for example he holds that opinion
yes so now brothers are you going to
follow the opinion are you going to say
no we don't follow that now yeah no
double standards yeah now you're going
to follow it is your wife is going to
put in the contract you're going to say
no I don't follow this why there's a
difference of opinion so now you accept
difference opinion now you accept the
difference opinion okay so um another
thing for example clearly says from the
of the Prophet mm PE upon him when the
sahab came and said that he got married
and the prophet PE be upon him said did
you see her go and see something in her
that will incline you to marry her eyes
so what they take from this and hes and
mistak follows that is that the
following if a man comes to ask for your
daughter's hand and if he follow opinion
he is allowed to see your
daughters your sisters and if it's your
mother that's getting married if you're
the guardian her hair up to her elbows
if I'm not mistaken up to the elbows and
or also the ankles she can dress up in a
she can dress up in some kind of a
clothing that is yeah not AA for that
matter but decent clothing are you okay
with that bro are you okay with that
opinion we going to say you have prot
jealousy this is opinion valid opinion
valid opinion not only that I actually
Incorporated this when I was getting to
know a sister for marriage I went to the
house and I said I would like to see um
if she's okay with it of of course with
a permission I would like to see you
without the hijab yep I because I'm
myself I Incorporated
this so is is there is there a problem
now do you see when the pick and choose
it happens when it comes toim giv
opinion the B show it's free mixing free
mixing free mixing free mix free mixing
okay good when it comes to the nikab
difference opinion when it comes to
contract in in can't get a second wife
difference of opinion when it comes to
your sister or your daughter or your
mother hair showing for the Sut Etc no
no no no no you won't do that stop
picking and choosing guys follow the
Quran and the Sunnah don't take your
over the that's the point that I'm
saying now like I said before these are
the scholars that we got the fat from
finally two individuals who are known
and praised by binaz the reason I
mention bin Bas is just to make it clear
because the brothers from that side's
camp they follow him that's the only
reason I'm not seeing this that bad is
only scholar he's not he's not the only
scholar may Allah bless and preserve him
he's done tremendous efforts for the
um albani alhamdulillah you know and
like when it comes to like the issue
of's opinion that I don't believe the fa
is here is the first one the first one
is I'm sure you guys seen him in one PA
Network alhamdulillah she D yes she D
alhamdulillah he needs no introduction
Subhan Allah you can watch his video on
one PA Network those of you don't not
know he is an Alim this is this is this
is this is a a a a common knowledge
Subhan Allah okay this is a common
knowledge that is the fat that he gave
and here is the voice recording let's
listen to it for ourself
so guys you heard that for yourself
Subhan Allah and I said this before no
one has ever come to me about the sh
freix I this first time I heard it was
from a person of knowledge a student of
knowledge a high student of knowledge
who came with this ruling I have never
come across any student of knowledge who
have came to me and said the show was
free mixing they came to other issue of
the woman showing their hair s showing
their hair those who do not even know
how to wear the hijab sister who came
because they don't know how to wear
aldah and the same thing she D mentioned
which is the topics and when it comes to
the uncovering woman that was an issue
which we alhamdulillah the scholars have
told us that we are working on and we
went to who because I know when it comes
to some Fringe group of our super Sal
Brothers going to say oh you know some
Scholars spoke no problem you know what
I said because majority of people when
they hear yes when they hear him it's a
mic drop it's it's the Matter's done
close done I also went
toan who was directly sent to the UK by
to do da and just for those brothers who
were extra extra Fringe I went to him
and he allowed me to make his fatwa
public here's what he said after I sent
him the recording of she that you guys
heard he said waum I was thinking on the
same lines as that of Muhammed
alassan I agree with his fatwa as well I
saido has allowed us to make his fatwa
public as people are accusing us of free
mixing so we wanted to clear the doubt
can I ask for permission to say you
agree with his fatwa he said yes you may
this is who shib Hassan again a person
who needs no introduction no
introduction at all so now the matter at
hand is very clear the big one of the
biggest Fitness that we have is the
breakdown of the family unit you don't
know how dangerous divorce rates are you
don't know how dangerous it is W one of
the biggest thing Shayan attacks the
Muslim um with is divorce the show is
there to reverse that watch it it is
beneficial you don't want to watch it
thank you very much go you don't you
don't like it brother unsubscribe
bye-bye
[Music]